saluant un ou dix on fait des petits
yeux toi non crash dans le lavabo là
pour voir c'est bien ce que je pensais
[Musique]
fumer du cannabis est interdit sauf si
on est malade
enfin dans certains pays ça peut
paraître difficile à comprendre ça peut
même sembler un peu injuste mais le fait
est que le cannabis comme les
médicaments il à ses indications c'est à
dire les cas dans lesquels on peut en
donner
mais aussi ses contre-indications c'est
à dire les cas dans lesquels il est
déconseillé et même des effets
indésirables mais là je crois qu'on se
comprendre le principe actif
c'est-à-dire ce qui provoque les effets
qu'on connaît du cannabis c'est le
tétrahydrocannabinol mais on va
l'appeler le thc si vous voulez bien
même si vous voulez pas d'ailleurs thc
d'affaires quoi le thc donc c'est une
substance de la famille des
cannabinoïdes et des cannabinoïdes on
n'en trouve pas que dans les clips de
snoop dogg ou dans les un stade rien à
notre corps on sécrète aussi on appelle
ça les cannabinoïde endogène ou
endocannabinoïdes est le plus connu
c'est l'allemand david alan d'hamid ça
vient du sanskrit ananda non ananda qui
veut dire bonheur suprême des attitudes
féliciter et de hamid qui n'est pas prêt
non mais un composé chimique organique
sa découverte est assez récente 1 1992
et son rôle est encore mal connu mais ce
serait un neurotransmetteur ou plutôt un
euro modulateurs c'est à dire une
substance qui modifie la façon dont les
cellules nerveuses communiquent entre
elles les endocannabinoïdes agissent en
se fixant sur des récepteurs
cannabinoïdes présent sur certains de
nos neurones
quand quelqu'un consomment du cannabis
ou n'importe quelle forme le thc bien se
fixer sur ces récepteurs et comme son
taux est beaucoup plus élevé que celui
des endocannabinoïdes il vient perturber
les fonctions concernées les
endocannabinoïdes on sait pas encore
très précisément à quoi ils servent
mais on sait que leurs récepteurs se
trouvent principalement dans le cerveau
et le système nerveux central et
notamment au niveau du système limbique
responsable de la régulation des
émotions du thalamus qui s'occupe des
perceptions sensorielles ce qui explique
parfois certaines modifications de la
vue
ou l'audition du cervelet chargé de la
motricité c'est la raison pour laquelle
le cannabis peut ralentir les mouvements
et donner quelques problèmes de
coordination si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire mais aussi du cortex et le
l'hippocampe siège de la mémoire mais ça
on va reparler plus tard les
endocannabinoïdes ont aussi un rôle dans
la libération de la dopamine qui joue
elle un rôle clé dans le plaisir
c'est ce qui explique cet état
d'euphorie que vous ne connaissez pas
puisque vous ne suivez pas de cannabis
bien sûr pour finir sachez qu on trouve
aussi des récepteurs cannabinoïdes dans
l'utérus les testicules l'intestin la
vessie la rétine et qui sont moins
actifs que ceux du cerveau et qui en a
aussi au niveau du système immunitaire
bon mais je vous vois venir vous allez
me dire oui c'est bien mignon tout ces
salamalecs mais nous ce qu'on veut
savoir c'est pourquoi ça donne les yeux
rouges comme ça oui voilà c'est ça qu'on
veut savoir est pas tout et salma hayek
oui bon bah de seconde j'arrive de tht
un effet vasodilatateur c'est-à-dire qui
dilate un certain nombre de vaisseaux
sanguins et notamment dans les yeux
au niveau des conjonctive c'est ce qui
donne cette couleur rouge cet effet
vasodilatateur il a aussi une autre
conséquence celle de provoquer des
chutes de tension quand on se lève un
peu trop doctes et oui parce que dans un
gros tuyau il ya toujours moins de
pression que dans un petit tuyau des
sarments tu peux pas le savoir a hélas
vous allez me demander à la bouche sèche
alors pourquoi ça de la bouche sèche
pourquoi c'est de la bouche sèche comme
ça on peut se tutoyer
si le cannabis donne la bouche sèche
c'est parce que la nand hamid joue un
rôle dans la régulation de l'appétit
du coup il ya des récepteurs dans les
glandes salivaires et il peut avoir pour
fonction de ralentir la production de
salive voire de la stopper
quand les récepteurs sont saturés de thc
d'ailleurs avant cros me pose la
question
la raison pour laquelle le cannabis ça
donne six fins a longtemps était pas
très clair mais une équipe de chercheurs
de yale qui pensent avoir trouvé une
explication le cannabis perturberait un
neurone habituellement chargé de
transmettre l'information sur la satiété
c'est-à-dire l'information selon
laquelle le corps a eu sa dose et que
c'est plus la peine de manger à la place
le neurone perturbé se mettra à
transmettre le signal de la fin c'est à
dire le message exactement inverse
n'importe quoi là
l'assaut est dépression jean-michel
neurones à votre écoute
oui oh ah ouais bon là en haut et c'est
moche pour la guadeloupe
non non mais écoutez bref on cendres à
l'évidence ça va jamais sa revanche et
votre histoire là mais non mais c'est
foutu mon vieux laisser tout tomber à
l'eau à nos îles dont intérêts c'est
quoi votre marque de cigarettes là ça
m'a tout perturbé j'aime bien sauf qu'en
l'occurrence transmettent le mauvais
message ça peut être très positif c'est
même l'une des indications de ce qu'on
appelle le cannabis thérapeutique où le
cannabis médical mais ça on en parlera
dans une prochaine vidéo parce que là ça
fait déjà un moment que je parle et que
vous allez autre chose à faire alors à
très très bientôt
[Musique]